foreign
do you know what the realm is
it's the Thousand Blades of aegon's
enemies a story we agreed to tell each
other over and
forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones
in-house of the Dragon update video in
this video we will be looking at all the
new photos released by HBO this is
another great way of figuring out what's
going to be happening in the new episode
on this Sunday another thing I want to
do is show you the breaking news stories
regarding House of the dragon's second
season only a few hours ago we found out
HBO will begin filming the second season
of House of the Dragon later this spring
this is obviously great news because I
know most of us are really excited for
the next season when the dance of the
Dragons will officially be underway I
think the second season will be far
better than the first one but maybe
that's just me alright so now we will
look at this new article regarding
actress Elizabeth Olsen now for those of
you who don't know there have been
articles written about Elizabeth Olsen
joining House of the Dragon for its
second season I actually made a video
about this only last week many fans have
been speculating that Elizabeth Olsen
would be in House of the Dragon next
year well thanks to the actress finally
addressing this herself we now know this
is false Elizabeth Olsen said she
doesn't know how all this started but
she will not be in the next season of
House of the Dragon now let's have a
look at HBO's new official photos let's
see what will be happening in the new
episode on this Sunday one of the major
events that will be happening in The
Following episode will be lady Elena
valerion's funeral ceremony on driftmark
as you all know lady Lena died in the
last episode after she had her Dragon
vegar burn her alive she gave herself to
the dragon flame after realizing her and
her unborn daughter would not survive
the operation in a scene that was
deleted from the last episode it looks
like Damon did grieve his wife's loss
with his daughters you can see that here
in the new photo unfortunately for some
reason they did delete a few scenes from
Damon's time over on essos now after the
death of his wife lady Lena valerion her
body was brought back to her home on
driftmark where they will be holding
this ceremony most likely at the very
beginning of the episode in these new
photos you can see all the different
characters who will be there in this
photo we get a great shot of King
viserys Targaryen on his right side you
can see his wife Allison Hightower while
standing on their left side as their
daughter Helena Targaryen once again
Alison Hightower has all of her children
wearing the green of her house now since
we all know viserys is softer than baby
[ __ ] he doesn't say anything about his
daughter and even his damn son showing
nothing but allegiance to their mother's
house we can also see Lady Elena's
father mother and daughter standing on
the right side of the photo as you can
imagine they're all mourning the loss of
their daughter now in the next photo we
see Laura Corliss valerion's brother
vamon valerion if you remember he was
there during the battle on the
stepstones against the crab feeder then
we have rhaenyra Targaryen and her son's
jacaris and lucari's valerion they're
all here to show some love because as we
all know raniera is married to Lady
Lena's brother Leonor valerion in the
next shot we see Lord Corliss having a
discussion with his grandson lucari's
valerion now we all know renera's Sons
were fathered by Sir Harwin but as of
right now they are still officially
lenor's sons and Laura his grandsons we
also get a great shot of Damon and Lady
Elena's daughter who is resting her head
on her grandmother's shoulder Rainey
Targaryen we also have a new shot of
Serato Hightower after he's arrived back
in King's Landing as you can see he's
giving sir Kristen Cole the side eye
which is interesting because sir Kristen
is now in the service of his daughter
Allison Hightower it does make me wonder
if Serato is unsure about Sir Kristen
Cole's loyalty I'll be very interested
in seeing how their relationship unfolds
maybe they will do things a little
differently than George R Martin's novel
Fire and Blood next we see Lenor
valerion who's looking very upset for
some reason while he's most likely
inside of his family's home on driftmark
maybe he's upset about the loss of his
sister or maybe this has something to do
with his friend Carl Corey as you can
see in this other new photo here is Sir
lenor's friend looking shady as hell in
the new episode on this Sunday we should
see cerlenor valerion fight his former
friend who went with him the Dragonstone
when him and raniero left the city one
of these men will not make it out of
that fight alive then we have King
viserys and his brother Damon while
they're on driftmark during lady Elena's
funeral ceremony now there could be a
number of different things they're
discussing since they haven't seen each
other in so long maybe they're catching
up or viserys is helping him deal with
the loss of his wife we shall see once
again we have another shot of aceres who
is still looking old and frail as hell I
gotta give it to him this man just won't
die no matter how sick he actually is he
has been living on his last leg for well
over a decade we also see Alison
Hightower who I believe is on our way to
driftmark for the funeral we get another
shot of her with her firstborn son aegon
hopefully she's letting him know that he
must stop acting like such a damn weirdo
this dude is on the verge of becoming
another Joffrey if she doesn't get his
ass in line very soon now let's go
inside a house valerion's home on
driftmark this should be another one of
this episode's major events when
rhaenyra and Allison's Sons fight each
other as you can see rhaenys looks very
upset while she she guards her
granddaughters Bayla and Reina Targaryen
I believe this is shortly after aemon
steals the dragon vagar which will
ultimately lead to him fighting
raniera's sons while aemon is looking to
mount vagar raniera's youngest son
Joffrey sees him so in order for aemon
to make sure he keeps his mouth shut he
not only slaps him around but he
threatens him as well as aemon is riding
on vegar Joffrey goes and gets his older
brothers jacaris and lucari's valerion
then as soon as aemon lands vegar they
begin fighting and It ultimately leads
to aim on losing his eye when this
happens Allison demands Justice she
wants renera's son to lose an eye as
well but viserys doesn't allow that to
happen I think this is when Alison will
grab the dagger herself and run at
renera my guess is this is how the
episode will end after this everyone
will know exactly how ranira and Allison
feel about each other making the rest of
the episodes very interesting and I say
that because I think this is when
Allison will most likely start making
arrangements for her takeover of King's
Landing this is how renera staying on
Dragonstone will come back to bite her
in the ass because she won't be there in
the city to do anything about it if I
were you I would get ready folks because
I think this is when the show is about
to finally go to the next level now that
we're just about done with all the damn
time jumps from here on out House of the
Dragon should begin to unfold like a
regular story only this one has incest
and dragons and murder three of my
favorite ingredients let me know what
all of you think about the new photos
also let me know your thoughts on HBO
filming its second season next year as
well as Elizabeth Olsen finally
confirming she will not be in the show I
am interested in hearing what you have
to say as always I want to thank all of
you for watching my video I hope you all
have a great day I will see you again
very soon bye
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign